when you're a clone you never alone
orphan black season 1 and ya know I'm
not exactly being timely on this but a
friend of mine loaned me a her DVD copy
of the first season I have watched it
I've enjoyed it I plan to keep going and
you know what I'm gonna give my thoughts
on it now it's all my intention for this
to be a spoiler heavy kind of video but
I am gonna be talking pretty freely
about everything that I witnessed in the
entirety of the first season and some of
it is going to be spoilers so if that
matters to you you might want to go away
right now before you do I will say it's
worth see it's very good stuff and I'm
really intrigued about where it's gonna
go in the future there go see it if
you're still around I'm assuming you're
either caught up or you don't care I
suppose the main thing to say is just
how well executed this thing is cuz I
knew was about clones going in even
though honestly as far as actual
progression in terms of how much new
information gets learned by the end of
the season there isn't a heck of a lot
that you learn new it's still really
intriguing and a lot of that comes down
to the way the characters interact and
how interesting they are to watch now
obviously that has to absolutely come
off to Tatiana maslany who plays the all
the different clones and she makes each
of these characters so insanely distinct
I mean not just in terms of voice and
she does flawless accents but just
everything about the personality like
you can instantly you know who each of
them are they just they distinguished so
wonderfully that said some of them
worked better than others obviously we
spend the most time with Sarah and at
present she is my favorite one but
really at least as far as this first
season is concerned she's designed to be
she's the one we spend the most time
with she's the ones we get to know the
best she's the one whose motivations we
understand the most so I definitely like
her Alison grew on me over time and by
the end I did like her initially I
wasn't a huge fan of her just because
her neuroses kept causing all these
problems and she seemed more like an
obstacle than a character but she's
actually really layered and I'm grown to
like her quite a bit Cosima
I haven't really made a call on at this
point I think large is just because
she's been primarily an exposition dump
and she's also Tina's slightly by the
fact that
really like what happened with her and
Delphine and yes it's fine that it's a
woman and that's the Oprah gressive and
yay for all that but the thing is I
think people would have been up in arms
about how stupid it was and how quickly
they fell for each other and how much
that became a driving plot motivator for
Cosima if that had been a man people
would have said it was stupid and it
belittled the character and all this
other stuff in as far as I'm concerned
you don't take the curse off of that by
making it a woman you make it slightly
more interesting but it's still
problematic for me yeah I know there's
me crapping all over romantic subplots
again I what can I say it's what I do
Rachel Duncan gets introduced don't know
enough about her can't make a call that
leaves me with Elena now Hellena I
actually do have problems with I think
she's got some issues in terms of how
she's written it again the performance
is stellar but I think from a writing
perspective they made her too damaged
she's almost infantile in like she
doesn't seem to understand just how the
world works and I get that that really
does show just how damaged she is and
how badly tamasam has treated her but
she's so broken to the point that I
can't imagine Tomas actually continuing
to send her out in missions in the real
world I would think as soon as she
started to question a mission you
stopped sending her out because she's
obviously got this mind that's very
malleable and very subject to influence
so that to me first of all makes her
slightly less interesting in the first
place and it really makes less sense
that she would ever get sent out into
the world ever again I think a much
better balance would be a character like
alpha from Joss Whedon's show dollhouse
who was the character who's very clearly
damaged and broken and unhinged but is
together enough and cohesive enough in
his brain workings to be legitimately
dangerous Hellena is just she's a little
bit too feral and that actually doesn't
make her I'm predictable that makes her
more predictable as far as I'm concerned
I want somebody that I can't quite pin
down because I can't quite figure out
exactly how much of this is illegitimate
damage and how much of this is she knows
what she's doing but I feel like I've
got her figure it out and I she bores me
a little bit pretty much all the rest of
the supporting cast though is really
spot-on Felix grew on me he was another
one I didn't care for off the bat but
his chemistry with Elle
other characters I mean with sera
especially is just wonderful so he works
really well Vic I was surprised I didn't
get an R by each time he kept showing up
but it's he's just an energetic fun
performance and it brings a nice thing
to the proceedings I really liked dr.
leekie but I'm biased cuz I love Matt
Frewer he's one of my favorite actors
he's one of those guys who does not
always do good movies or good TV shows
but is always good in anything he does
actually choose to do I also really like
art because art is an archetype that I
like because he's the guy who's he's got
no agenda he's just trying to figure out
what's going on he's just trying to make
the best decisions based on what he
knows it yeah it's it reminds me a
little bit like of Davos from Game of
Thrones just somebody who is just trying
to be the best person they can be in a
really messed-up situation and so I like
that type of character and he plays that
very well Paul he kind of up and down on
again there's the romance angle and but
they're not banking on it too heavily
with him at least not yet and
performance is layered enough that I'm
willing to accept him I don't love him
but I can live with him I thought you
didn't work though Olivier I'm just
gonna chalk that up to miss casting the
guy just wasn't intimidating he wasn't
intriguing he was just flat he didn't
work as far as plot in the way the story
unfolds it's again it's really
impressive how intrigued and invested
they got me given that not all that much
is different at the end of the season
versus at the start I mean the
characters know a little bit more about
each other but it doesn't feel like a
full season worth of information has
been learned by the end but it's still
oddly satisfying and it never felt like
wheels were spinning it always felt like
things were moving forward and the show
was for the most part pretty smart in
its decisions in terms of what the
characters did and how it got from
situation to situation and how it got
out of a lot of situations that were
like what have they just written
themselves into a corner with that look
with things like Sarah pretending to be
Beth which really felt like something
that they was gonna just put them in a
corner really quickly but I was
surprised how well that kept continuing
to pay really good dividend so again
just really well executed on a lot of
these ideas that's it
at the end they it did one thing
specifically that I hated so much that I
need to talk about I'm trying to avoid
nitpicks with this thing because there
were little things across the show but
this just just drove me crazy when Kira
left the house with Hellena
that I did I could not believe they did
that cuz it just makes no sense based on
what we know about Kira up to that point
Kira is shown to be a sharp kid she
recognized immediately when she saw a
clone that wasn't her mother trying to
pretend it was her mother and she has
been demonstrated in that very same
episode as being kid who tries to be a
good kid yes kids make mistakes every
now and then but she tries to be good
and do the right thing by the people who
are the authorities in her life so the
idea that she would open up to the door
and then leave the house in the middle
of the night while her mother is right
there no I don't buy it I don't believe
it was a fundamental betrayal of
everything I knew about that character
up to that point and then ultimately the
do we just so they can get her hit by a
car and then be like oh there's
something weird going on with Kira it's
like there had to have been a better way
to get us into that situation and to get
us that information because this was so
contrived it was one of those things
that they just they broke a character in
order to force a plot event and it was
so ham-fisted completely
uncharacteristic of almost everything
else the show does but it stuck out so
badly I can't not talk about it cuz I
hated that moment I think that's my
biggest complaint like I said I've
gotten nitpicky things some of which as
time has gone on I'm prepared to let go
others I could go on about but it
doesn't seem worth it because the show
was still really interesting and like I
said wonderfully performed by pretty
much everybody involved so I'm
definitely gonna keep with this series
and catch to hopefully catch up before
season 4 starts airing I don't know if
I'll do more videos on season 2 or
season 3 as I see them but if I feel
like and I may come back depending on
response to this one but in any case
have you watched orphan black what were
your thoughts on the first season do me
a favor and please don't drop a bunch of
spoilers for the lady two seasons in the
comments don't be a jerk but in any case
whatever your thoughts about the show in
general and the first season in
particular drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned